bad mom's Christmas okay you mila kunis
Kathryn Hahn you are terrific together
you guys well and you can tell that you
like each other yeah we do we do we
really really and in fact I get so much
oxytocin when I work with them because
particularly when we're out of context
that sounds bad but anyone who didn't
hear the explanation in the first
segment who's just chilling in the oxy
told yeah yeah you know yeah the reason
we all get oxy together released in your
brain when you have a wonderful physical
contact or someone so when we are like
doing interviews like on a couch like
this the first interview always starts
with us trying to like suck in our
bellies and and play the game and then
by the third or fourth interview we're
all just like sort of hanging over each
other or like you know yeah and again
you touch each other but that's we like
holding hands and we're really good
friends and that's that you know that's
your choice yeah that's your journey I
appreciate you there's nothing wrong
with that I just like to film it it's a
lot of it's on camera yeah yeah I'm a
creep you guys did a scene this movie
where you give Santa a lap dance yeah
and I think we have a picture from the
scene of you ladies getting down on
Santa and I'm just curious how does an
actress prepare for that moment
well Conan I did prepare for that moment
all I did was stretch really right but I
stretched it was 2:00 in the morning it
was like a mall in Atlanta we were so
tired and we knew we were gonna have to
like really go crazy during this dance
sequence and I'm like I'm definitely
gonna pull something so I did stretch it
fully before and then also because I am
NOT just a bad mom I'm a good mom I
stretched afterwards yeah this is
important to stretch afterwards you guys
when you're giving Santa a lap dance
make sure you stretch before and after
the lap dance that's important you gotta
do both
you